did you see them last week did you watch
them last week in in in brighton
hopelessly would hopelessly divided i
thought they looked their leader like a
seriously rattled bus conductor
pushed this way and that by
not they have bus conductors anymore
unfortunately but like a serious a
seriously rattled bus conductor pushed
this there this way this way and that by
a corbin eastern mob of sellotape
spectacled solute or the
or the skipper of a cruise liner that's
been captured by somali pirates
desperately trying to negotiate a change
of course and then changing his mind and
remember labour's performance during the
pandemic flapping with all the
conviction of a damp tea tile they
refused to say that that schools were
safe uh they would have kept us in the
european medicines agency and slammed
the brakes on the vaccine roll out there
the the labor leader attacked the
vaccine task force for spending money on
outreach to vaccine hesitant minority
groups when it's hard to think of any
better use of public money and let us
forgive him on the basis he probably
didn't know what he was talking about
but
it in in previous
[Applause]
in previous national crises labor
leaders have opted to minimize public
anxiety and confusion by not trying to
score cheap party political points by
thinks of uh of atlea or even michael
foote in the falklands crisis and sadly
that was not the approach taken by
captain heinz attacking one week rowing
in behind it when it seemed to be
working the human weathervane the the
starma chameleon and in his final absurd
act of opportunism he decided to oppose
step four he opposed step four of the
road map in july remember that's right
folks if we listen to captain hindsight
today we'd still be in lockdown we
wouldn't have the fastest growth in the
g7 if columbus had listened to captain
hindsight he'd be famous for having
discovered tenerife
how are you
absolutely
how awfully astronomy